On Friday Jake said the word he heard me say the word once and then I walked outside
And then I walked back inside, and then he walked back out so then I walked back outside, and he walked back inside
That's 160 by definition
Because every time it doubles
103 - even till I do 160
The issue is when I was filming he was only able to do 16
And he never finished the last 64 and that was on Friday, Today's Tuesday. Rule states that whenever you leave a location it doubles
Saturday, Sunday, Monday and on Tuesday. He just walked out of the hall again God
God knows Jake has an infinite amount of push-ups owed to the game of life God's when he when he gets back
We'll do the math with him. I don't know how I did. I don't you're not gonna cash in on all these push-ups
There's no way. No, He's gonna be in the infinite debt
Why
What sort of trap are you walking me into right now? Nothing, what do you do
this weekend?
went out with my
motorcycle club I
Hung out with my daughter. I was at home a lot
I had a pin bend in my ar-15, and so I replaced it well
It sounded like to me you went somewhere with your motorcycle club
Yeah, okay, then you went home you went to clean up your garage went back into your house works in my office
I worked on that's in the kind of the same place. Yeah, got a lot done around the house. Jake
Friday you went home with 64 push-ups still owed to the game of life
I see where this is going I thought about this when I left on Friday you dog
I need to I need to sue for peace. Let's do 10
I got double this 8 time if it would appease the gods of the game to have me
Carmichael you're in debt by 16384 push-ups. listen, listen, listen
This isn't chicago, this is the wild fucking west
Consider me like Floyd Mayweather right now. pre McGregor fight, okay?
I owed a bunch of money to the IRS on tax from money that I made from the Pacquiao fight, okay
But I didn't have the money to pay it, but if you gave me if you give me some time
To have another fight
Then instead of instead of the IRS losing out on twenty eight million dollars
They can get all that money, but they're gonna need to wait
This is a similar situation you can come to an agreement a payment plan yeah
I mean it's like we need to come to a situation where you know everyone wins because you're not gonna get all that debt
Why don't we just talk about some Stevens bucks for a little bit?
I was hoping you wouldn't think about this. I got home on Friday, and I was sitting there eating dinner, and and I just looked up and went *gasps*
It's your own game! I know dude, I know. There's two ways out of this we can figure out a value of
equivalence between a number of push-ups to Stephen bucks
We can do the more entertaining thing which is for the next year till next September 5th you do 45 push-ups a day
Just like a student loan
I have a game of life mortgage
oh no, a game of life mortgage
Could see this as an opportunity and wake up every morning and curse Carmichael's name and do 45 push-ups
How about this, how about this, how about this... I got a solution
Five Stevens bucks go to the bank, and I will do 45 push-ups a day
till
the end of this year, okay, it's so half. It's literally half. Yeah, sixty-eight push-ups a day for the rest of this year no
Im agreeing to 40 a day +5 Stevens bucks
Which is
which is equivalent me getting it done by the end of the year is equivalent to the 22 that you lose sure per day I
So okay, 60, so the total
16384 equivalent to ten point nine, so round it down to ten, so ten Stephen bucks a half of the Stephens bucks
you have 68 push-ups a day to get through if
You've decided to 45 per day
The banks are losing and push-ups what I'm saying is what I'm going to guarantee in this arrangement is
I'm going to get it done by December 31st
2017. You can't be too stubborn about these sort of things
You
Have a deal here. We go. Thank you. Thank you two thirds agreed
We have a deal all right, so starting today 45 push-ups a day
For the rest of the year
plus 5 Stephens bucks in the bank
Yep alright, let's get it going
One
I feel like you're pretty happy about the deal of  not going for 365 days
They're only gonna get easier from here right we want to try something new for the rest of this week for the next seven days
Will be a daily vlog marathon, so please hit that subscribe button
Share and tell people to come over and watch this 'cause you love it, so they should love it too. Thanks. See you tomorrow